okay playing Mahmud Mohammed I mood okay  let's play play d5 I'll play a gambit  but I'll try and be sound oh do I play  the h5 line all I'm so yeah let's play  h5 o this job this chap has such a high  success rate  g5 the bishop is trapped Oh too much fun  each for it's hard to play this without  laughing  black doesn't deserve to win a piece  playing h5 on move - and why just  playing normal moose I'll develop the  rook cuz why not get some lifting in Oh  what to do rook before that's such a  bizarre like I've just pushed pawns and  lifted my rook so far but I'm being  rewarded I'm attacking upon do I take  upon I could take up on my rook my rook  has there's the only piece that I've  moved so far away chess resides I think  that has to go on YouTube it's another  dumb and dirty London opening h5 trap  you two people beware beware of the  dirty trap and beware of rook lifts yeah  they're slightly terrifying  okay back to tournament